all right um
mike d finn's uk should the dolphins
draft a quarterback at three or trade
down shereen chances are
that there will be two quarterbacks gone
in the first two picks
trevor lawrence and zach wilson
what do you think the dolphins should do
have they seen enough from tua to say
let's take a shot with another franchise
quarterback like the cardinals did a
couple of years ago or should they give
to another shot and get some other area
of need addressed
i haven't seen enough of tua but they've
certainly seen him in practice and and
apparently think that he's the real deal
at least they've said that publicly mike
and i get no indication that they're
gonna use the third pick on a
quarterback if i had any question at all
that tua is the real deal i'm drafting a
quarterback with the third pick if i
don't have a question if i think too as
my quarterback i'm going to trade down
and get those additional picks because
boy mike
they can really get a haul out of this
draft that will set them up to contend
for the next few years if indeed tua is
the real deal
yeah and it all comes down to how you
feel about whoever is going to be left
after lawrence and wilson
do you really feel strongly about
that guy who whoever it is and
desean watson is a is a factor in all of
this too i mean there have been ugly
incidents that eventually have gone away
and
that doesn't make any of it right i'm
just saying this is not something that i
mean i mean michael vick went to federal
prison for two years and he was back in
the nfl i i think that at some point
the dolphins
need to make a football decision about
whether or not this is a move they want
to try to make understanding that there
will be pr fallout
but um and and and understanding and
coming to a conclusion as whether or not
they think that he did what he did again
if he did what he did and this is where
i struggle in this landmine if he did
what he did he gets everything he
deserves but even then that doesn't mean
he goes to prison for the rest of his
life i i don't i mean maybe some of
these allegations would set him up for a
long prison sentence if he gets
prosecuted but for civil lawsuits
whatever the verdict is you just move on
and uh yeah he'd be punished by the
league but it's not like he'll never
play again he's still fairly young so
that's part of what these teams have to
factor into their analysis
yeah i could see deshaun watson playing
for the dolphins one day mike that's a
great point because
you know they they have a quarterback
they could trade and they obviously have
draft capital this year and it doesn't
look like it's going to happen before
the draft this year but at some point i
could see the dolphins being in play for
deshaun watson
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports